“Migration Portraiture”
“When the subject
is strong
simplicity
is the only way to treat it.”
-Jacob Lawrence
North
First time Colored could sit
on something moving fast for free,
ride the shoe leather of the train
all the way up to men
standing on Harlem corners
with faces like ours,
they, moving along in a white man’s coat
never nodding back our way.
Cotton still stuck in their shoes,
Zoots! waiting to be shipped back
to green pastures.
Sixty.
South
The snapped bloody rope
the undertaker pulled off my Jack’s neck
is wrapped around
my little girl’s depot suitcase
like a wedding garter,
tight.
Recognize, I tell her.
Decamp from the field,
learn to read blood on a rope
like an encyclopedia,
then Get!
Persimmon hat pulled back
sideways on her little head,
pencil eyes pointing that a way.
Sixty.
South
From Mexico to Carolina
they tore through cotton
like beetles from the Bible.
We human boll weevils sally forth now,
ready to land in a new northern field,
push our long snouts
down into the bud
of something fat and sweet
and suck.
A three-lettered poison
will help the cotton
ride the rails back.
What about dusty black us?
Sixty.
North
Mama hammers hot steel
pretending she is a man
in a heavy heat suit.
Her bald head and sexless hands
pay for coal and bread
and new books.
On the new fire escape she whispers
and smokes,
I didn’t come all this way to clean
and polish another white house,
then asks me to memorize
her new northern words,
Flying & Dutchman.
Sixty.